[Music]
wow
i saw a very difficult situation a
police motorbike that hit a wall and a
policeman next to it who was shot he
looked dead i took over the situation i
checked for gunshot wounds he'd been
injured
[Music]
this is according to israeli prime
minister naftali bennett a wave of
terror attacks he called it in fact a
wave of arab terror attacks and he said
that they would be dealt with with an
iron fist but certainly it is a very
major security crisis domestically for
israel
[Music]
this is a great and complex challenge
for the army the security agency and the
police that requires the security
establishment to be creative and for us
to adapt ourselves to the new threat and
read the tell-tale signs of lone
individuals sometimes without
organizational affiliation and to be in
control on the ground
[Music]
the west bank will suffer now even more
because as it seems now the attacker
came from the west bank so i guess they
will send more troops and do more
arrests but by the end of the day
those actions
will not prevent the next attack the
occupation continues to be as brutal as
it is as cruel as it is you cannot be
surprised because as long as this
occupation will go on there will be a
price
[Music]